am anfang steht ein kilo hier das
eingeständnis dass ich eine wette
verloren habe eine wette die wir anfang
september hier noch bei viertel nach
acht durchgeführt haben ich habe
gewettet dass olaf scholz nicht
bundeskanzler wird und muss sagen mit
dem heutigen tag bin ich eines besseren
belehrt worden
oder schaut dass bundeskanzler das
erfreut viele millionen wählerinnen und
wählern und er hat heute noch mal wieder
versucht auch bei der stabübergabe im
kanzleramt wir sehen hier ein paar
bilder auf kontinuität zu setzen hat
doch auch im sinne von angela merkel
gesprochen die mitarbeiterinnen und
mitarbeiter im kanzleramt entsprechend
adressiert und ich glaube dass die
größte gefahr die uns droht also nach
angela merkel darf es keinen olaf merkel
geben was wir brauchen ist eine komplett
neue politik wir dürfen uns nicht mehr
von krise zu krise regieren lassen
sondern müssen richtige schwere und
nötige reformen anpacken beispielsweise
beim thema rente beim thema steuern beim
thema bildung beim thema digitalisierung
die liste ist sehr lang von daher mein
appell herr scholz wagen sie auf jeden
fall weniger angela merkel und wagen sie
gerade was die großen reformen angeht
vielmehr gerhard schröder
[Musik]
ja ich finde erst mal gehört es sich
auch aus der opposition heraus zu
gratulieren das haben ich und viele
andere heute deswegen auch getan und ich
hoffe auch im sinne deutschlands dass
olaf scholz und dass die ampel koalition
möglichst gute arbeit macht bei in der
tat brauchen wir gerade in diesem
jahrzehnt in den 2020er jahren große
reformen wenn ich auf die sozialen
sicherungssysteme schaue da werden wir
immer mehr ältere menschen haben die
auch immer länger rente beziehen und
gleichzeitig gibt es immer weniger die
nachkommen bzw die einzahlen und da
brauchen wir antworten darauf also zum
beispiel wird es glaube ich gar nicht
anders möglich sein in einigen berufen
auch länger zu arbeiten weil ansonsten
die sozialen sicherungssysteme nicht
mehr lange finanziert werden können
wobei ich explizit auch sagen möchte
damit meine ich jetzt nicht den
dachdecker oder die möbelpacker oder
diejenigen die hart körperlich arbeiten
müssen sondern er mit blick auf bürojobs
und gleichzeitig müssen wir gucken dass
die digitalisierung in deutschland
vorangetrieben wird auch durch
schnelleres planen und bauen und da
hoffe ich dass olaf scholz tatsächlich
sich eher an dirk schröder erinnert als
an seinen linken spd-flügel sie als cdu
politiker sagen auch ganz klar da haben
wir in den letzten 16 jahren eigentlich
bei entscheidenden reform viel zu wenig
getan sondern angela merkel war zu
schläfrig hätte das lg hat schröder
schon gebraucht was die reform angeht in
dieser sache also ich würde sagen angela
merkel schon sehr viel positives auch
für unser land getan zum beispiel hat
sie das außenpolitische ansehen
deutschlands gemehrt wir haben die
geringste jugendarbeitslosigkeit in
deutschland wir haben auch jetzt so
viele jobs sie noch nie aber natürlich
gibt es auch einen reformbedarf den kann
man glaube ich auch nicht wegdiskutieren
und deswegen hoffe ich dass olaf scholz
eben eher an gerhard schröder anknüpft
als an kevin kühnert aber diese job
geschichte bela du warst der
regierungssprecher unter gerhard
schröder das jobwunder was angela merkel
auch erlebt hat dass wir diesen großen
tag eigentlich auf das konto von gerhard
schröder ist schön dass jetzt in diesen
heiligen hallen alles zu der damaligen
zeit die erkenntnis gereift ist dass
dieses der fall ist denn auf diese
schlacht sein habe ich damals zumindest
gewartet als regierungssprecher dass das
alles gerd schröder und seine agenda
2010 zu verdanken ist ja alles andere
leute dabei darf ich hier einmal
nachfrage ich habe letztens mit eltern
gesprochen von der cdu bringen sie zu
mir gesagt haben im hintergrundgespräch
es wird immer allen gerhard schröder
gedankt und agenda 2010 und sie müssen
sagen die cdu hat aber auch deutlich
mitgeholfen das ist die agenda 2010
jahren ich war in dem deutschen
bundestag als gerd schröder seine rede
gehalten hat so agenda 2010 und ungefähr
so in der richtung in der du jetzt saß
vor mir er friedrich merz und der damals
einer der stellvertretende
fraktionsvorsitzende glaube ich war der
cdu/csu wenn ich sogar
fraktionsvorsitzender aber ich glaube
aber stellvertreter und an das gesicht
und an seine gesten und an seine mimik
den ich sehr schätze werde ich mich mein
leben lang erinnern da war nicht so viel
support
ich habe gerhard schröder wirklich
hinter dem ich saß so zwei drei meter
wirklich bewundert wie er in einer
solchen situation die kontrolle behalten
können und so eine schwierige rede da
auch entsprechend positiv rüber bringen
könnt also da war nix mit support das
war danach anders im
vermittlungsausschuss muss
nicht im namen der agenda 2010 nochmal
durchgefochten werden durch gekämpft
werden da gab es dann auch
zugeständnisse von seiten der union
peilt man musste weil man dabei muss
reiz als trainer muss ich weiß dass noch
ich war junger abgeordneter und war
schon überrascht wie wie schröder das
gemacht hat bekam auch anfeindungen beim
rentenfaktor zum beispiel war aber da
und das fertig ist für politik wichtig
und das glaube ich ist für die nächsten
jahre auch wichtig war dann auf einmal
aber jemand der auf die vorwürfe lautes
rufen aber sie haben doch und damit
haben sie die wahl von habe gesagt ja
zur cdu waren fehler und hat sofort
weiter geredet und man merkte wie und
das ist die reformen die notwendig ist
wo man manchen stellen ist oder zieht
jetzt aber auch einer durch und das wird
für die ampelkoalition glaube ich
bestimmten stellen so sein dass sie dann
durchziehen muss gewiss sicherlich auch
matti kritik auf sich ziehen wird aber
am ende wird ja nicht gefragt war es
nett sondern was bleibt und wo beim
thema rente ganz speziell da muss man ja
sagen hat zumindest die fdp nicht
richtig gut verhandelt oder anders
gesagt hat sich möglicherweise von
grünen spd massiv über den tisch ziehen
lassen bei diesem thema denn wenn ich
dann wieder wenn ich sehe wie viel ärger
wir für die aktien rente bekommen habe
ich das genau andere gefühl dass wir
also ich kriege immer mit von bergen und
anderen die sind viel ärger und wie
könnt ihr nur eine aktien rente machen
rentner an den kapitalmarkt nein liebe
rentner wir beteiligen euch endlich an
den gewinnen der große vitra die fdp
ausschließen dass es eine anhebung des
renteneintrittsalters geben muss wie
kann die fdp sagen wir stabilisieren
quasi mit einem untergrenze das
rentenniveau ziehen also eine grenze
halt und sagen bis 48 prozent tiefer
darf es gerne alte roste evers der
janney koste es was es wolle was an der
stelle sicherlich nicht gehen da gibt es
noch so eine art schuldenbremse in der
verfassung die auch irgendwann sagt die
frage hätte ja da habt ihr sehr viele in
der großen koalition unter merkel ich
glaube ältesten gemacht wie wir jetzt es
gibt wird kein einziger schattenhaushalt
geschaffen also kurz entspannen verträge
einmal noch ganz klar sie sagen die
schuldenbremse wird gelten und ihr reich
zeitig haben wir eine rentenkasse die
mehr geld braucht weil sie sich was die
einnahmeseite angeht und was die
ausnahmen seite angeht gewisse grenzen
auf ihren ausgaben werden steigen ganz
klar einen seite ist ein gewisser martin
einsteigt nennen die einnahmenseite
steigt dann schon das muss man ja auch
sehen wir haben gegenwärtig selbst in
der krise steigende einnahmen in der
rentenkasse weil wir die beschäftigung
haben halten können auch wiederum wegen
der sicherungsmaßnahmen damals
eingeführt haben wegen des
kurzarbeitergeldes und andere dinge mehr
die frage ob die rentenkasse
funktioniert wird von der frage abhängig
wo die arbeitslosigkeit steckt und das
möchte ich dann doch noch mal sagen das
entscheidende für die rentenkasse wird
was ganz anderes sein nämlich solche
leute wie ich ich bin nämlich jahrgang
1965 die baby boomer da wird die frage
sich daran entscheiden ob wir das
hinbekommen und nicht ob wir bei uns auf
unsere generation sagt hey und es ist
immer gut gegangen war wisst ihr was 63
frührente wer gut vielleicht noch ein
bisschen früher oder weiteren arbeiten
aber auch über lange arbeiten bis macht
einmal 60 das ja der punkt dass moment
die frage ob man länger arbeiten kann
die frage was das bedeutet ob ich zum
beispiel dann am ende wenig später in
rente gehe dadurch auch vorteile haben
und das für mich nutzen will diese
flexibilität die wollen wir gerade ist
auch so ein stück von der fdp was auch
wieder von gewalt das ist franz
müntefering zu zitieren volksschule
sauerland also wenn die menschen immer
länger ich immer lese immer länger immer
länger rente beziehen wenn es immer mehr
menschen gibt die eine rente bekommen
wenn es nun mal weniger gibt die
einzahlen also brauchen wir alle nicht
mathematik zu studieren um zu wissen da
gibt es große probleme und jetzt geht ja
schon jeder dritte euro als zuschuss vom
bundeshaus sich durch in die rentenkasse
jeder dürfe was die cdu uns darüber
gerne die fdp der auch mit riegeln
gesehen glaub ich glaube wir sollten
jetzt auch geistig tönt anders aber die
leute ja nicht angefangen vielleicht
vielleicht einmal ausreden lassen ich
glaube nur ganz wichtiges und da drücke
ich ihnen ja die daumen also ist ja gar
nicht so dass ich jetzt sagt da haben
sie versagt sie sind ja jetzt seit ein
paar stunden in mit der regierung in
werfen würden aber ich glaube da müssen
sie tatsächlich an und das problem ist
welche im koalitionsvertrag schaue da
gibt es auch seitens der fdp keine
antworten sondern das problem wird
ausgesessen und genau das haben wir als
in rente aber genau deswegen aber die
aktion wir nicht sehr langfristige
lösung die nicht in vier oder fünf
jahren hilft